皆さんアイドルといえば0 akb48
ご存じでしょうかあのー昔からすごい人気で僕は高校の時から jal さんのめちゃ
好きだったんですけどその札行したりいろいろメンバーでつい買ったり揺らしてに
ロンドンちなみに押し目は akb48ってチーム8がチームけどは純ビートあるん
ですけども私でもをしているのは cm 8の
奥いいじゃんという子なんですよ
[音楽]
ネット者2万人に1人といっていうねおぎーちゃんっていう方がいるんですけども今日
なんと
このスタジオに
うっております
日清水を前にどういう話ができるのかっていう僕もちょっとわからないです固まったら
ごめんなさい文章が出たらごめんなさいひとみ氏が出たらその後けどちょっとあの1回
程度皆さんに2万人に一人の美少女見ていただきたい
そして好きになって欲しいだけで今日は akb チーム8を gree ちゃんとお
話ししてみたいと思いますね by こう
ていただきましょうお米ちゃーん
こんにちはああ
いいんでしょ
よろしくよろしくお願いしまう
医師によっていただいたじゃない
乗って姫
麻生創作一旦スって私いただきますね5位
いただきました twitter で服を取ったんですよ一緒にまとめました
ございます
かわいいですね
いいはい
[音楽]
チームいいとも小栗ですよろし
ていますすいません
ou の前が引いて驚け2万年にする日ソジョリアルでも本物だったぞ
あっぽん子ですかはいぜひ本当に帰ってきたんですけどさぁ
かわいいですねーなんと理解
[音楽]
すごいなんで始めました
社長という
あーなぜはじめ冊をという名前になるん
大学の時にまだったので
学生起業ん
この夏を会社をつくって儲けようで話を振っ
その時に殺王のポジション
だったんですよねすごい君はなかった
イクーッ
me
ブルーハーツやんなくてそんな声出る
いや
キャッチ私これから youtube をはじめよう
お金が来たいいよって言うありますか
こえりえーの顔面1時間耐久とかあって
頑迷一直で1体でもそうだけど9時間ですけれども
えええええ
すごくありますよ何を頂いたろぅ
最高にしないや前1回やってみてください youtube
よかったなという
あったらって思った
金がもらえるん
おおおっ照れて顔を手で覆っている仕草がかわいい数
フュージョン趣味とかなんか
[音楽]
てい
あっお米唯ちゃん月度いことを言ってこのっている
回し蹴りねっ
呉で抑え
[音楽]
牝5サービス
あとは
他の国の言葉を
あいさつ
[音楽]
んでした
どうしてますかはい
あ護衛者ひどいことを言ってこの時は大変に出せなかったけど本当に酷い事をすると
思ってる横日にゆいちゃ
[音楽]
あってルビーのとかめっちゃれている
ええええ
遊べそうですね
[音楽]
遊べそうです
周囲に散っ
入らないしてますか
今日はねえっ
b が横うそー
頑張ろうと思ってい
腕が過労という
んじょい聞くだけで鯛つりそうになります
は18歳
マーカーいい
8歳男児ね
どんなイメージです
goo
ええええええ
[音楽]
んだなぁと思う
あああん
思っ思います6
たいなと思います
んなことないですけど若いけど
そのめっちゃわけでもないかん
指切り
アウトロたいですねっ
握りやるとか
わきがって
[音楽]
me
ん
[音楽]
それだよということだ雄どんな大人になりたい
入ったを
も自分を持っている
future も持ってるんん
なれるしもう神はあるよ
ん
本のだった
プランテルいいぞ夏菜抜ける奴いいです
かわいいのまで行って
なります
書かれますなりますねぇ
女をしてい
me
篭弁当とかねぇ
どれにしようてもそれで1時間くらい蹴ることも
のすごい
[音楽]
ねっクラー
そんなん
[音楽]
1桁でもって
a n キタ郎
はいね万人に一人の美小だと思う言われていますがぶっちゃけと思います
いやー
すごいプレッシャーにすごくさ
今て
すぐ2
3 hane
ハードカ所あった
すごいするやねぇ
対象次がと思ってたんですけどぬーん
オンワードデー
すごい知ってくださいね
て銀箔カー審問で1本になってくだ
みるします2する
今を監視していた
まさに本人に塗料と思いますよね
40,000
したり
4番年に4万人にしたり
手と手が私いたずら勝ち越し好きねぇ
[音楽]
ん
て驚かせ
から優しいですねっっ柑橘
まあ空を舞いますね
成功いたずらしてません
by がお風呂に入っということで爆竹と畑てますねっ
まくちぐすい
6関数スパッジオたぜぃで煙ガールズ予想でした
大変でした
私は4日
ぜひやってみてくださいねあうん
んえっ
んじゃないですかないでー
つかいつかず店の5日ですねおっ
[音楽]
新納出来上がった
ん
皆さんが薄い金髪とこの現象を見ているその
えっ
赤レールもねます
ダイソーん
電子ビット送られなければいいというか
はいまでも
ん
ぐったんですか greater 奴車
まあをされたかったですミドリっ
緑区違います私はに抑えるん
[音楽]
voodoo
ぷっちょ